there's a lot of this stuff with PTSD
there's a lot of people that claim that
a lot of other men are like claim P and
women or people are claiming pts like
there's a lot of like a scam like with
ensuring you know like people getting
money do you do you feel like that is
putting like a bad gloss on men that are
actually suffering do you hear anything
about that well there's there's I would
say that there's probably a portion of
people that claim to have PTSD and don't
really have any good reason for PTSD and
I'd say there's a lot of guys that say
that they don't have PTSD and actually
do have some PTSD so terrain is there's
a lot of guys that don't want to admit
to it that but I think we're getting
better about that as we get better about
saying hey it's okay if you've got PTSD
a lot of people go oh is it okay well
then I guess I had PTSD too or I have
PTSD too so I would say there's some of
that out there and I think I'm not quite
sure what to do about that or how to
handle that but I think that guys for me
you know when I meet a guy that's been
through a lot you know I just want to
help him out yeah whatever whatever way
we can and make sure that they are
getting the help that they need and if
we help some people that don't really
need it
okay I mean that's that's that might be
the the sacrifice that we make mmm
that's a good way to look at it would
you ever um would you ever have to be
deployed again or no no cuz I retired he
did yeah but if [ __ ] hit the fan can we
count on you I'd be back too right ready
to rock and roll that's cool did I went
to know that the series answer that
isn't I fully retired so unless we get
like level 9 World War 3 going on I
probably won't be participating and to
more important than that there's plenty
of guys in in the military right now
that are way better than me and they got
it handled
yeah yeah man I went to UM you know over
the years I did some different just
going and doing some service of we went
to Iraq one time or Kant went to Arif
John one time when I went to that it's
like a base for somewhere people laying
and a lot of planes land I think it's in
Saudi Arabia maybe but they had a moment
where there's this alarm that goes off
if something comes into the base
and then everybody's just kind of
standing there and you're waiting to see
like if something is gonna blow the
[ __ ] building off yeah yeah yeah and
it was like it bro is the craziest thing
I didn't know and I'd never been around
what were you in a bunker did you get
did they get you into a bunker of some
kind no we were I was actually in the
gym and and it just went off I guess
somebody come over one of the fences and
this is alarm and it was just one of the
most scariest things that it had ever
heard yes and been a part of because
basically then what I was waiting for 30
seconds to see if I was gonna be alive
it was like a really shitty game show
kinda yeah so so that sucks
and then like I've been in a couple
situations where I was getting mortared
and you but I've actually heard mortar
launches so now you know they're coming
and you don't know and it's just a it's
just a roll the dice at that point but
then again that's like you're shaking
head like oh my god that that's nothing
compared to like when we were talking
about earlier about world war 1 where
these guys were taking that sustained
bombardment of massive like I'm talking
about oh I had nine more Gers shot at me
these guys had tens if not hundreds of
thousands of artillery rounds fired at
them there was millions of rounds like
before the I think was the Battle of the
Somme before the Battle of Somme they
fired 1.6 million rounds at the enemy
before they started so we're talking a
whole nother level and that's why you
see guys go watch some World War to
World War 1 videos on shell-shocked it's
it's one of the most horrible things you
can see and it also shows you how
fragile the human mind is and that
there's guys that would go blind they
there's nothing wrong they never got hit
but they would go blind or they'd go
deaf or they'd go mute because their
mind would just completely shut down
when they couldn't control their body
anymore it's it's a horrible thing so
I'm glad you got to experience one
one-millionth of a fraction of a percent
of that when you were in Saudi Arabia no
and the horn went off and and but
seriously take that take that hour
action of a second and use multiply it
to infinitely and that's that's what
these guys experienced I can't even
imagine what these guys I mean I can't
even fathom is it
is it so loud that you can't think or
does that start is that like how it is
the first couple of times you hear like
some explosions and then it starts to
adjust you know it's weird your mind
does some things
when there's situations going on that
I'm sure you've heard this before that
things slowed you've been a car accident
and things slowed down to things slow
down yes yeah so there's that there's
also some selective hearing that starts
to take place where you can hear things
like a voice that you might not normally
here because there's loud gunfire or
whatever so there's some things that
your mind does in that survival mode
that are very effective and make you a
little bit more ready to to handle a
situation at hand do you start to have
your faith adjust as you went through
experiences like that like did you have
any was there anything like that that
kind of happened for you you know for me
my sort of like my patriotism like it is
what it is it was what it was it's it's
does it get strengthened like I'll tell
you the thing that strengthened me more
than anything is is from a faith
perspective is like you get to see guys
that put their friends above themselves
Wow and and and you know I guys that put
their their own lives their friends
lives above their own lives and when you
see that is it pretty incredible if
there's an there's there's a you know
maybe it's not a doctrinal religious
element to that but there is a there is
a deeply spiritual power 'fl thing when
someone says you know what I'm gonna
make sure and and you know this this
happened with one of my guys named Mike
Mansoor um you know there was a grenade
thrown onto a roof and there was three
guys up there with him and he jumped on
that grenade and and he sacrificed his
life for his friends and if that's not a
of spirituality and belief and he was a
very faithful guy he was a believer in
God and you know I think that with
seeing that and knowing that with you
know just understanding that that can
happen and that that's that's a religion
unto its own the way that we treat each
other in the sacrifice we can
make for each other there's uh there's a
religion right there kind of that's
powerful man yeah thanks for sharing
some of this good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one